yeah thank you very much
um yeah welcome to my talk today I'm
very happy to give you a little
introduction in Bluetooth low energy
Python and how to build this simple
project on Linux a little bit about
myself so uh yeah as I said I'm my name
is Bruno Falmer I'm the co-founder and
CTO of bipet which I'm going to talk
more about later my background is in
pretty much standard computer science
from rwth and if you have want to know
more about biped and everything else
you'll find more information on my
website as well
little disclaimer there will be some
slides with some more information you
will find those also in the description
of the talk I've built a little example
because we're going to go through some
code which you also find later and as a
little Point here I mean this the whole
reason for this talk was me going
through that Journey from an absolute
beginner to somebody having built
something with ble so I'm not an expert
I would say I pretty much understand
everything now it works in practice but
I'm also not part of Blues or the
special interest group which is doing
the Bluetooth Center
so what are we talking about today
um this whole talk is about a practical
perspective on Linux Python and
Bluetooth but there is still some Core
Concepts that everybody needs to
understand to understand my examples
later so there will be some basic
introduction into Bluetooth low energy
we'll then go through some code look at
something and then I'm going to finish
off with some practical tips tools and
pitfalls to avoid so that you don't have
to sit there for hours wondering why
stuff doesn't work we won't have in time
to go too much into the code example
itself that's why it's on GitHub we
won't have time to go into the protocol
details as well I'm happy to explain
some stuff afterwards or answer a
question and there's also no time to go
into any kind of communication
optimization
okay as a little motivation where I'm
coming from and why I'm working with
this as I said before I'm the co-founder
of biped which is a device for blind and
visually impaired people the idea is
basically you wear it over the shoulders
it consists of a camera module a
computer and a battery in the back and
the idea is that it can detect track and
predict the trajectories of all
obstacles in your environment
and additionally give you also
navigational GPS instructions so
basically to tell you how to go from A
to B if you cannot see and how do we do
that is
very similar to how a parking assistant
of a car would work so if we detect an
obstacle in a certain direction we will
play from that direction a sound which
indicates the obstacle with the
repetition rate to how close that
obstacle is on top of that we layer the
navigation information and all of that
you hear through open headphones for
example bone conduction headphones where
you can still hear your environment but
you also hear the audio because the cues
that we give you and when we started
working on this two years ago we quite
quickly realized that we will need some
sort of interface or communication
mechanism to configure the device to
work with it which is not the device
itself so we decided okay we need a way
to communicate between a phone and the
device itself and if you look at there
is multiple options out there we decided
okay we need some sort of requirements
fairly simple list it has to be
something that we can quickly prototype
together to try it it has to be quite
energy efficient because our device is
fairly battery restricted so you don't
want like you want the battery to be
used for something else for mainly the
the vision perception processing and
then you want it to be fast because we
also wanted to use the device and use
the the app to display some like
real-time Pro debug information and I
mean it will not come as a surprise what
we decided for
um it's like Bluetooth energy was in the
end
the main reason and the question I get
at this point is usually why not
Bluetooth itself main reason being if
you want to work with classic Bluetooth
on devices that are produced by Apple
you better have a few legal like lawyers
ready and a lot of spare time to prepare
this because there's a bunch of legal
Hoops you have to jump through while ble
in itself is not at all restricted by
Apple so that's why
including all the other reasons we
decided for ble
um when I then started my journey into
ble I quite quickly realized there's a
lot of information available for
implementing so what I will explain
later is there's two sides to the
communication in BB and what I realized
there's a lot of information and
Frameworks available to do the site that
runs on the phone but there's not really
a lot of information available for
running the site that runs on the
peripheral so on the site in case our
device or whatever a smart watch
whatsoever and so to get that like to
avoid that somebody else has to go
through the same struggle and to give a
bit of a starting point that was the
basic idea of this talk today
so as promised a little reminder of how
Billy works and what the Core Concepts
are about
um just to where Billy comes from Bill e
is basically a lightweight subset of
classic Bluetooth classic Bluetooth is
what you know for example with streams
audio to your headphones and it was
introduced in the Bluetooth 4.0 standard
which is governed by the Bluetooth
special interest group it's a Industry
Group where a lot of like big companies
are part of and the idea was basically
to give a simple communication mechanism
to communicate between devices and
modern mobile platforms this also
includes laptops but it was mainly
designed for phones
and the main difference here is instead
of having an open stream that
continuously pushes data back and forth
we have a device that sleeps between
Communications and those Communications
are also designed to be maximum a few
seconds long and that has as a two main
side effects is we save a lot of battery
so we can run it on very battery
restricted devices as well as the fact
that the through the design of the
protocol our connection and buildup of
the connection is a lot faster than with
classic Bluetooth it does have the big
downside though that we can send only
very limited data
one of the few things you need to know
within ble is the generic access profile
gap which basically controls how
connections and advertising Works in
Bluetooth this Gip defines two types of
devices which is a central and a
peripheral central is here the example
for a phone a powerful device with a lot
of battery and then we have a peripheral
which could be smart watch Beacon all
kinds of like light bulbs whatever
and the idea here is that through the
definition of the Gip we only allow to
advertise and then later on also connect
between a peripheral and a central
there's no way to connect between two
peripherals
and there is also no way to connect
between two centers this is important to
know what it does allow though is that
one peripheral can advertise to multiple
centrals at the same time and that's
basically the idea behind beacons
because
um if you have I don't know some smart
homes have these beacons the idea is
basically that because you don't even
have to connect to them you can
advertise to multiple phones at the same
time and that's how Bluetooth speakers
work
the second important definition is the
that of the generic attribute profile of
short Gatt which defines how once we
have found our device we want to connect
to the whole connection process work so
it describes how the two day two devices
can transfer data back and forth and I
think the first important thing to know
is that once you have decided to connect
this connection is exclusive so you
cannot connect a peripheral to two
centrals at the same time but you can
only have that once
then what you have is what is called the
attribute protocol ATT and I'm going to
stop with this with this long names for
stuff after this which defines basically
how the data is shared between those
devices and what the structure of this
is and the ADT basically has two main
definitions and I think those are the
most important things to remember from
today if you Billy is new to you a
service and a characteristic where the
service is used to break up data into
logical entities and then a service can
hold multiple characteristics and the
characteristic is then what actually
encapsulates the data the single data
point so this could be a value imagine
like a heartbeat a battery value a small
string or something like small array
and this data together is hold in a
simple lookup table where each of the
services and the characteristics have a
uuid that in most cases 128 bits long if
it's custom but the Bluetooth special
interest group because we have really
something that is really restricted on
all the messages you can send they also
Define some standard Services some
standard characteristics and those those
have a custom 16-bit uuid so if for
example you want to build a heartbeat
sensor the heartbeat service and
characteristic have its predefined 60
Minute address which is better because
then you can send more stuff other stuff
that you want to send
the way it works basically and don't be
I just replace the names so basically
what we're talking about from now on
until the end of the talk is the GATT
client and GATT server which I'm just
going to call client and server for
Simplicity
um we're still talking about phone and
peripheral
um is that the phone initiates the
connection and then the server or the
peripheral actually holds all the
information on what kind of data it
wants to share right and so this is the
important part to know is that you
define the data within the server and
then you send it back it sends it back
it's in reality it's been more
complicated but I simplified it here
um okay that's all the concepts you need
to know there's obviously more to it but
for this example that's all that it is
to know at the end of the talk there's a
long list of resource which you can go
through endless amounts of PDFs if
you're more interested in this
um now we are here to learn how to do
that on Linux with python first thing to
know is this only works on Linux doesn't
work on Mac OS doesn't work on Windows
like this
basic idea here is we have in this case
for example a Raspberry Pi which has a
Bluetooth controller we have Linux
running on it and what we use is the
Bluetooth stack that is part of the
Linux kernel which is called Blues Blues
implements all that logic I told you
about it also will implements a lot of
more stuff Bluetooth classic stuff and
so we want from our application to talk
to Blues to tell it hey create a server
whatsoever we cannot do this directly
but as it is I would say fairly common
within the Linux kernel is we have to do
that through a communication way which
is called dbus which is dbus is a
messaging oriented middleware which just
allows multiple processes system or user
processes in the Linux kernel to
communicate with each other and the fair
like basic idea is you put a message on
the bus and then some other processors
can pick that message up and do whatever
they want with it
like little important thing to know
because that's what's going to pop up in
the examples later on quite a lot is the
concept the three important Concepts
within dbus are service object and
interface
basically services use what is red to
wrap everything the object is actually
what is owned by the process and then
the interfaces with an object it hers to
so it's a method a signal or a variable
okay and so this is how it would look in
code
um I mean this is like strongly
simplified but so we have we're defining
here uh the descriptor Class A
descriptor in the context of ble is what
like every time you have a
characteristic you have a little text
with describe what this characteristic
is about that is basically what the
descriptor is and so we're extending the
debus object
um and then the object in itself then
implements the debus property interface
which is used for blues to tell what
kind of properties the descriptor has
okay
I was not sure if I should do a live
demo or not many people told me not to
do it because it's probably going to
break so you will just have to trust me
the code worked before I can also
showcase it afterwards but I'm not going
to do the live demo but we're just going
to go through the code anyways the demo
would have been pretty boring because it
just sees some terminal output
um before I go into this uh general idea
is this is one way to design it right
this is my way that worked for us this
is the simplified version of this I'm
pretty sure there's multiple other ways
to do it in our setup here what we have
is we have our main process which is
super simple in the example but
basically this holds all the logic that
is supposed to do something with the
data then we have the Billy process
which initiates sets up our server tells
the server like tells Blues how it that
character is like how our Gatt server
should look like what characteristics
and services we have and then we
basically have um I mean the phone index
with Blues but then interacts indirectly
with those parts so that we can then
communicate them back very classic with
cues right this is one way to design
this the idea is pretty straightforward
and I think the important thing to know
is just that the whole ble process that
is based on the debus event Loop because
it's asynchronous and so the idea is
basically that we use callbacks and
queues to get that into play and so if
we look at our code
um I mean this is the main function
right this is very straightforward the
only thing we're basically doing is
we're creating the queue we're then
creating the process we're starting it
and then the only thing we do is we have
a while loop going on and on just
checking if there is something within
the queue there there will be the place
where you place all kind of logic
whatever you want to do
then um
we have our ble process and here I think
the important part to know is that this
is where we create with the all the
debus
important things and then we create the
service manager which is the interface
which implements the interface where we
actually Define our Gatt server and then
we create an advertisement and here I
mean you remember what I showed you
about the
objects which then implement
interfaces and so here we have the
interface which is the once again the
properties interface which then gives
all the information that for example our
advertisement has and this could be this
is a bunch of stuff that advertisement
in ble allows you it's I mean we've put
some fake manufacturer data it's the
service uids that we actually advertise
in this case we just have one service
which we advertise a name and all kinds
of other things that are not important
right now
um so we create this advertisement and
then the whole wrapper around
the thing is what is called an
application here
and so we the application once again
is the like it's a debus object and the
important thing here to know the
function we're overwriting is the object
the get managed object function which
just returns like every part like every
service and every serves it returns
every characteristic again within every
characteristic it returns every
descriptor and that's basically all it
does
um and then the interesting part comes
this is where we can now create custom
Services where we add custom
characteristics and we can add them to
the application
add them to the application initialize
the advertisement register the
application so all everything has to be
added before we register the application
and then run our blocking call here and
the interesting part is in those four
functions which we override because this
is where the callbacks come into place
in the main Loop so every somebody
writes for example to a characteristic
we will then have this function called
where for example we do something super
simple we just put that written value
into the queue and you can do whatever
you want with it same goes for the read
value where at the moment we just set a
default value to each characteristic we
just returned that and I think
uh the important thing to notice here is
that when you have what is called
notification within Bluetooth flow
energies where you notify the other side
hey I've made a change to that
peripheral uh to that characteristic
that is based on a function which is
continuously called so what I'm doing
here is I every 10 milliseconds I'm
calling this input queue callback and so
that would be one way to implement the
fact that you have this input queue
where from our main process we can just
whenever something's ready say hey write
that value then you will have to build
some logic that the service gives it to
the right characteristic but in the end
in this function you can then check hey
is there a new value available if yes
then we'll just set that value so that
on the next read it also works and we
set the properties changed which will
indicate to the other side hey there has
been something happening and that's
basically the core idea of the whole
project
um and so if we go back to our
presentation
I want to finish off a bit this with um
like some tips tricks and tools because
I found especially I mean with a lot of
other
um things you can do with python there's
a lot there's a lot of
example tutorials available where they
show you okay this is something how you
can do this and this is this and I found
this was not the case here and to avoid
having being you in the same situation
as us where we're completely confused
what is happening and we don't really
know how to debug this this is uh
basically the idea here the most
important tool arguably is Bluetooth
which is your command line interface
with
um with Blues so basically that comes
with Blues so once you have Blues
installed on your Linux machine which
all the standard linuxes have by default
you can use Bluetooth CTL to do all
kinds of operations with Bluetooth you
can do as something as simple as
powering on and off your Bluetooth but
you can also do stuff like scanning for
devices and so on and you can actually
create for example a Gatt server just
from the command line and this is
important to know because Bluetooth CTL
also just uses debus
and the idea here really is that
um
basically everything that Bluetooth CTL
can do you can do in your application
because once you've run Bluetooth CTL
and in the second terminal vendor you
turn on the debus monitoring which you
have to tune a bit so that you don't get
all the debuss messages but just the
ones you're interested in you can
actually just see what
um Bluetooth CTL does and then try to
replicate that in your
um in your application so it's basically
here for example when we wanted to
implement some pairing logic where you
want to have for example ask for a pin
or something I don't know when you
connect to a Car Bluetooth you have this
always then what we just did is we
replicated that behavior and Bluetooth
CTL looked at what it does under the
hood with the dbas Monitor and then had
this as a starting point on where to
attack this on the application side
um if you want to go a bit lower level
deeper into it you use a tool called
btmon also comes with blues and it's
basically you're monitoring
infrastructure to show you really the
low level HCI traces
first warning it's quite extensive so
once you have a connection with the
device this will spend hundreds and
hundreds of Lines within seconds and so
this is only I would say usable if you
look for something specific
um this came in handy for us when we
were especially looking on connection
stability so we had some problems with
iOS being quite unstable with our device
while Android was working fine and so
then we looked at the logs and see what
could cause that and this is always good
to have as a backup to look into this
um and then I just wanted to give some
ideas on like what could be possible
problems and what could be possible
solutions biggest problem in the end
um is like it's not a joke actually
restarting the Bluetooth service on your
machine helps I would say in 80 of the
cases
once you have figured that out
um
what I think the biggest thing was for
us was okay the advertisement wasn't
even showing up on our external device
so you have these test apps right which
just so all the Billy stuff in your
environment you have it running you have
the app it's not showing up
that would be basically something where
I would monitor the debus because dbus
won't tell your application directly hey
there's something wrong there is no
exception going with the throne but you
can have a look within the locks and
most of the times you just search for
error or something similar to that and
then you will find okay have you
forgotten to define something you
miswritten something or you did
something wrong
um the second thing I already told is
basically once you have this a bit more
complex setup between an app and a
device and there is some back in there
and you don't know which side it is what
I would usually just do is take one of
those test steps available for Android
for example light blue or iOS has also
some and then you would just custom you
could connect those to your device and
then write custom values to
um like to each of the characteristics
you can see the definition of the
characteristics is correct and so on and
then finally if the communication is
unstable or certain messages don't
arrive I would just look at the
Bluetooth monitoring and then some
pitfalls at the end I will just quickly
go over it so you can hear all of them
really be cautious about the fact that
there is some Max sizes defined for
different parts of the messages sent
especially for the advertisement for
example it is not possible to advertise
to custom services at once we found that
out the hard way because there's not
enough space in that message second
thing is IOS and Android do not behave
exactly the same on everything they have
both their own detailed implementations
of ble which I guess they didn't talk to
each other but they behave differently
and the big thing here for us that was
different is on Android we do not
actually pair the device we just have
the communication it works fine and on
iOS if you do not pair the connection
super unstable I cannot tell you right
now what the reason is but for example
there there's something where you have
to see how the different platforms
behave and it also is not enough to just
check one or the other and finally there
are some connection parameters for
errors but that is also part of this
thank you very much for listening I hope
it was clear and I'm open to give
[Applause]
okay thank you so much Bruno I'm going
to read out some questions on slido so
um is there any hope that Bluetooth on
Linux will get better in the future
I mean I I have to say it's um I'm a Mac
OS user myself for on the computer side
so uh but I guess they're actively
working on this so what you can see is
um for example Ubuntu is always quite
far behind on the blues versions so
um there is way a lot of newer versions
available
um so I would say if you really not by
this check out their newest um the
newest Blues versions update them
manually I mean I'm not taking any
responsibility if it breaks something
but generally I would say there is
always they are actively working on this
and they have a very active developer
community on slack as well if you're
interested in this cool
next question if ble isn't used for any
long connections then how would you for
example flash firmware to a device or is
it okay but just not recommended so yeah
that was one of the problems we had what
uh I mean yes I would not recommend
using ble for anything data intensive
like this
um what we do is basically that the
person over be indicates to the device
hey connect to the Wi-Fi then we do the
update over wi-fi and then we disconnect
the Wi-Fi again great so Martin Hecker
who's sitting to my right would like to
know can one device or computer be
Central and peripheral at the same time
to ease development
um I don't think that's possible but I
would not be 100 certain I think really
to
um what I've seen so far is that you
would really want like a big problem
with Bluetooth is that you really want
to try out the actual connection to see
to debug it so as I said for example
what we did in the beginning was we
worked a lot with Android only because I
assumed please behave the same on iOS
and
I tried it on iOS nothing worked and it
took quite some time to adjust it and to
do some custom and I'm I would recommend
trying it
directly and I would say it's not
possible but I'm not entirely sure
okay
so another question
um you mentioned stability issues with
iOS
um is was it just a rebooted issue an
apple issue or a you issue it was a
combination of an apple and US issue so
um the first thing that you like that is
not I feel like that could be more
proactively communicated by Apple is the
fact that Apple requires you to use like
they say Okay within a bleed connection
there's some parameters you can set and
they actively say if you don't set those
we don't guarantee anything and so what
they do is they would just randomly cut
the connection and so on once you set
those parameters there was also back
from our side which we then found
through ptmon so that's why I'm putting
it here but I would say it is a half off
okay James wants to know if I wanted to
try this at home do you know any good
starting device that doesn't require VC
money
yeah I mean in the end but really the
point of this was if you want to try
this at home take a Raspberry Pi and do
it right that's the whole point of it is
that I mean I think
be that the reason why nobody or the
weather is
known information about this is the fact
that mostly this is done by big
companies that produce those peripherals
and it's not something that a lot of I
would say
um like people want to do in their free
time or open sources there because yeah
there was not a lot of interest in our
case it was a special case right but I
would say super easily try it take a
Raspberry Pi at home do it and then it
should be fine
yep
the question was if I have experience
with esp32
[Laughter]
I mean I I personally have not with this
but I would say as long I mean this
stuff should be valid I mean I wrote
down the version but as long as blues is
part of the kernel
which I guess it is in this case but I'm
not sure right then it should work right
this is specifically targeted towards
Blues because Blues is the most used
Bluetooth stack within Linux
but I'm I would assume that because they
their way to implement the GATT server
is following the specification
everything else that would Implement
like an alternative driver and if they
follow the same specification the idea
would be the same I mean the stuff like
how characteristics and services work
they're predefined so there's not really
a lot of room I would say to do this
differently
Fair Point Fair Point no fair point
um I would say yes you're right it's
probably still not going to fit exactly
right also with the naming uh the debus
I mean you saw with debuff you have to
give a specific path always right the
naming will probably not fit because
they will probably use another naming
okay sorry we have to stop now yeah
okay thank you everybody for your
participation thank you again Bruno
thank you